[Music]
a storm only et was behind the scenes
with Marlon Wayans at YouTube space la
as he geared up for his new self-titled
NBC show are you using any of your real
life in this oh ok all your real life
your kids are growing up so fast
you opened up about having the sex talk
with his 17 year-old daughter a might
and fifteen-year-old son Shawn yeah look
I stopped being there dead a long time
ago I was like we're gonna be friends
cuz as a dad I don't be all possessive
like you I want to meet him I'll be
sitting there shining bullets no I want
to be um be your friend and I'm gonna
walk you through it
no you guys seem to be a dad cuz they're
little younger but at a point when they
become teenagers they're you know real
stuff you have to have real conversation
because what you don't want is sneaky
kids if you tell me what's poppin I can
protect you but don't come to me after
the fact like if you come to me and go
dad I'm I'm think about having sex I'm
like okay well here's what you need to
do and here's the protection you go
behind my back and you come to me tell
my dad my ding-dang ditching bro all I
can do is take it to the hospital
you know can't come in like dad I'm
pregnant whoa I'm not gonna do about
that if I know we're talking about the
divorce on this show in a different way
listen love is like water you pour it
into different glasses and it takes
shape and I'll always have nothing but
love and respect for that woman and I
think her is my family and you know I
think of when I look at my kids I see me
and I see her and when we all go to
dinner I date my family we go to dinner
we go to movies we hang out we laugh now
she won't give me nothing but that's
okay that's okay if I was her down
either as this should be you got to earn
this nice too much work you hold you all
that I'm being the club's before I let
you go I want to talk about the fact
that your love interest in this show is
miss essence yes she shines love
interest on the land we brothers we
share it's like Shanna shirt you know
it's like a Sean let me get it to be
your soda you don't trip what's it like
working with her she's awesome man that
woman gets me it's weird we have like
this is the set marriage man she just
gets me it's my set wife she when I'm on
set and I'm doing my little runs she's
always in pocket she's always just
supporting me always keeping us in the
scene while I'm doing all kind of crazy
stuff cheeses and that's hard
[Applause]
[Music]